delegate the responsibilities
of his protection to those who
would accept Islam from those
responsibilities were on the
shoulders of Abu Talib
previously. Abu Talib was
protecting the prophet with his
status, with his with his
authority there in in amongst
Quresh. And then Abu Talib
passed away. Khadijah passed
away. And so there was a
vacancy in that. So the prophet
decided to go to a in order to
call the notables there to
Islam. That if they would
accept Islam that they have the
ability to then protect him and
provide a haven for him. And
order to call to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala with
impunity and his efforts there
were rejected in a five and as
a matter of fact, he was harmed
very much in that. He was
turned away and he was attacked
verbally and otherwise in a
life. And so, the prophet
returned and his only companion
at the time was a person may
ask, well, why did he take
Zaidab in for instance? Why
didn't he go to if with Abu
Bakr for instance, Abu Bakr was
a closer companion and second
of all, Abu Bakr knew all of
the tribes and had very high
standing in above and the
reason for that is that Quraish
would not have allowed that.
They didn't know that he was
going to if for this reason. If
he would have prepared himself
and taken Abu Bakr for
instance, then, that would have
raised the suspicions of
Quraish and they would have
impeded his path there too. And
so, Zaidab and Harita,
remember, was his adopted son
and he was as Zaid Ibn Muhammad
up until the time of
the battle of Al Khandak when
was revealed and adoption was
abolished in that case. And so
the prophet taking Zaid Ibn
Harith it was very natural. It
didn't look they were
going to anything of the sort.
Just a normal travel as people
would at that time. So it would
not the suspicions Quraish
and their efforts would then be
magnified and impeding that.
And so
and so, when he arrived at
Aktar, if he invited the
notables of he invited all of
the people of Ataif,
individuals, people in the
streets, people in the market.
He had a session or a few
sessions with thee nobility of
Akbar if
inviting them to Islam,
reciting the Quran, etcetera.
showing of his miracles that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
provided him with And
unanimously the people of Allah
if rejected the prophet's
message. And not only that but
they escalated things to the
point of physical harm. And
pretty much drove him out in in
a very sense and so the prophet
retreated bloodied and battered
to a is a basically like
an orchard, right? You would
have these cons, it's the
desert. So, you would have
these concentrated places where
farmers have their date palms
and whatever else it is. So,
the prophet
retreated to such a place and
he remained there for a few
days. And some things
transpired when he was there at
that We have the very prominent
dua that is known of the
prophet when he retreated to
that area. He had been cut,
lacerated on his head, his
heels were bloody. They were
literally stoned out of a five.
So, he retreated for some
reprieve. There in that and
there is where he made his dua
to the end of the Dua. Oh
Allah, it is to you that I
complain. It is to you that I
that I bemoan the weakness of
myself and the lack of ability
that I have. To the end of it.
And in summary the essence of
that dua is oh Allah the people
have turned against me. And if
you are pleased with me then
that means that it doesn't
matter to me. Who is with me or
against me at that point. And
so, after having made this dua
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent
to him the angel of the
mountains. And was sent to the
prophet to ask him if he would
him to retaliate on his
behalf to the people of I mean
they unanimously disbelieved in
their messenger and the prophet
and they harmed him physically
and so this constitutes that
they be punished by Allah And
so he he asked the prophet what
he wished to do. If he wished
to basically clash the
mountains, clash them with the
mountains, basically destroy
them, eradicate them, and the
prophet
He said, I would rather that
they be left alone for yes,
these people have disbelieved
in me but perhaps, they will
come to have offspring that
will believe in me. And will
worship Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala without any partners.
Abdul Kaim says,
Allah
[Silence]
in much prayer and recitation
of the Quran and unbeknownst to
him, there was a group of the
that happened to be in the area
and they had actually gathered
around the prophet listening to
the Quran. And he knew nothing
of this. Until Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala sent down verses from
mentioning that a group of the
Jim had actually been there.
heard his recitation. And many
of them accepted Islam. This
was very good for his
confidence. This was showed
that there was some progress
being made. Even if not
progress with the people that
he had intended but we see that
what the prophet intended
didn't happen. However, because
of those efforts, others became
Muslim that otherwise would not
have. And if you think about
it, the prophets went to with
the intentions that the people
of except Islam that they
believe in him. They drove him
away. This was the only reason
that he ended up in that
orchard and this is the only
reason that those gin happen to
hear of him. And possibly the
only reason that they would
have become Muslim. Had that
not happened. Perhaps they
would have never heard about
Islam. That that group of the
Jin. Right? And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala didn't give
the prophet exactly what he had
intended. But he did give him a
fruit to his labor.
So, while he was there in this
orchard, he was contemplating
returning to Mecca. Now, they
were left without a choice now.
the return to Mecca and Zaid
asked the prophet how are we
going to go back into Mecca
when they essentially drove us
out. they drove us out. By
the time he had finished and
headed back. Quraish already
heard about what he had done
and where he had gone. And
basically did not want him to
come back. And so the prophet
said that indeed Allah is going
to make a way. He is going to
make this possible. And
regardless of what we see. It
is the promise of Allah that he
will raise his religion and
that he will raise and make
victorious his prophet.
Ibn Adi.
The
[Silence]
That he reenter Mecca under the
protection of Multaim Ibn Adi.
Now, Multime Ibn Adi was not a
Muslim. He's a non Muslim and
he died as a non Muslim, right?
Very similar to Abu Talib.
However, his son was became a
Muslim, became one of the great
reciters of the Quran, Mutraim.
And had a number of number of
good merits and and good
positions that he took. So, we
remember when the famine was
happening in Sheb Abu Talib
that roughly three years that
they spent there. When they
basically were under this kind
of embargo, right? Well, there
were six men that collaborated
to end that embargo. And of
them was he was one of those
six guys that convinced Quraish
to let off of the prophet and
so and and Benny Abdul
Muttalib. So, this was one of
the very numerous and very
significant positions that
Multiimubin Adi took.
Unfortunately, Abu Talib,
he did not accept Islam. He
died as a non Muslim upon the
religion of the pagan religion
of his forefathers but he had
some good traits and some
virtue
positions that he took and so,
he sent I'd to return. May
I return in your protection?
Said yes, told the man from
Hosea, tell him yes to come in
under my protection. Multi
Then, called to arms, his sons,
and his tribesmen, and said,
take up your arms and come with
me to the Kaaba. Because I have
granted protection to Muhammad.
To reenter into Mecca under my
protection.
Ibn
Masjid al Haram.
[Silence]
on his horse, on his riding
animal, whatever that was and
he announced to the nobility of
Quresh that noone is to harm
Muhammad in any way.
Because I have granted him
safety. I have granted him
safety in my care, in my
hospice. So, we will defend
that oath that I have given
him. And of course, his
tribesmen were with him wearing
their wearing their arms in
arms and so, it was clear that
this was very serious, meaning
that we're willing to take up
arms and protect this oath with
violence. So, this became very
clear and he was granted refuge
once again in Mecca. Fente
On Sarafa
the He
[Silence]
and the while was there with
his tribesmen and his sons in
arms protecting him and having
this display of protection all
the way until he was delivered
safely to his home. And so the
prophet has had a very
difficult year. This is why
this year in history and in
Sierra is referred to popularly
This is not in any narration or
anything. It's just popularly
referred to as Ahmed Husan, the
year of sadness. Why? Because
the prophet lost his wife. Then
he lost Abu Talib. And then he
was rejected from a Taif and
this triggered a whole other
level of aggression.
amongst Quraish towards him.
But as we've learned from the
Quran, as we've learned from
the ways of Allah Subhanahu wa
ta'ala that Allah never allows
the night to become too dark
upon his righteous servants.
Yes, night time is inevitable.
Yes, darkness must come. It has
to. That's the way that the
natural world is. it's a
daytime for a while and then
there's that contrast of night
time. However, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala never allows the
night to become too dark upon
his believing servants and so,
this was also the year in which
the night ascension took place
which is referred to as a
almighty. Al Isra was the night
journey from Mecca to Masjid al
Aqsa and Al
which was the ascension is when
the prophet ascended into the
seven heavens met various
prophets and messengers and had
a very critical dialogue with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
himself. And so historians
Muslim historians, the Islamic
scholars of history, they have
debated when took place. We
have to remember something. The
order of events the exact order
of events is not known
100percent. We have a most
likely order of events that the
majority of the scholars have
kind of agreed upon. And that's
what Ibn is presenting to us
here. But there is a difference
of opinion. I mean some of the
historians view that was in the
second year, the third year
after prophethood, the 13th
year, there was different,
different opinions But the most
correct well low Adam opinion
of the timing of is after the
famine, after the death of
Khadijah and after the death of
Khadijah and Abu Talib. And we
know this for a number of
reasons. We don't have any
dialogue recorded of the
prophet discussing Al Isra or
Al Miraj with Khadijah. That
would be a big issue, right?
You would think that would
occur and the person that he
would speak to about and
discloses to the first person
would be Khadijah but we don't
have any narration that.
We don't have any narration.
Explic mentioning that Abu
Talib ever heard of remember
now at that time, the the story
of is that he traveled in a
portion of the night, just a
small amount of time, he
traveled a month's journey from
Mecca to Al Masjid al Aqsa, and
then not only that, but
ascended into the heavens and
spoke to Allah. This is a huge
event, right? And so
this was a source or a point
of contention with Quraish.
Quraish ridiculed the prophet a
lot and said how how can you
even say that that's possible?
That's just absolutely blew
their mind. And you know today
that would be less of a shock,
right? Because of the kind of
travel that we have today.
Person can make a journey like
that. and that's not too
inconceivable but at that time,
the fastest travel available
was a postal a postal horse,
right? postal horse and a
postal horse is somebody who's
doesn't have a lot of gear.
They're just running on the on
these horses and passing off
postage to the next place. Even
in the of the Romans who had
perfected the postal service
and were one of the first known
civilizations to perfect the
postal service. This would have
been an ad vent of weeks at the
fastest to get from Mecca to Al
Aqsa. Let alone to go and
return. And in the same day it
was inconceivable that a human
being could travel that.
Right? For us with the kind of
travel that we have It's not so
inconceivable, right? But at
that time, no human being was
known to have traveled like
that, not even close, not even
slightly. It was beyond what
they could picture, what they
could imagine and so, this was
a huge event for the prophet
You have a question that comes
up and that is, what is, more,
significant, for the prophet
and for us The day when he
became a prophet or the day
when he ascended. And we would
say for us, the greater day in
the prophet life is the day
when was revealed. The first
day of his prophet. For us,
that's the most virtuous. For
the prophet his most virtuous
time, the pinnacle of his day,
his days was on that night of
this was the most significant
event in his entire legacy.
The
[Silence]
was not just his soul. Meaning,
if it were just his soul that
was taken. This would be akin
to a vision that a person sees
or a premonition. And that's
not something that is so
unfathomable and unbelievable
to Qureish. Quraish. Believe
and things that. Believed
in that there were things that
were beyond their grasp and
beyond their experience. What
was so alarming is that he
said, I really went in that
travel. I mean, I my body, all
of me went from Mecca to Al
Masjid al Akman from Al Masjid
Al Aqsa in my body ascended to
the heavens. This is what
caused so much
such a stir amongst Quresh,
right? And so and so there are
some scholars that have
mentioned or positive that this
night journey and ascension
occurred only with the prophet
soul. Just his soul alone. But
that is the weaker opinion. The
correct opinion and it's almost
absolutely the case. Is that
physically his body and his
soul? Was transported to Al
Masjid al Aqsa Roman Masjid al
Aqsa into the heavens.
He says,
better
[Silence]
For instance in the Arabic
language is lightning, right?
Is lightning. And Al Barack is
referred to as Al Barack with
that same with those same
letters and that same order.
The root word is shared. This
articulates swiftness and
blinding speed, right? And so
he rode this animal. This
animal is unclear what exactly
it was It was smaller than a
mule, bigger than a horse, and
it was extremely fast. Some
scholars mentioned that as its
eye sees, its hoof reaches,
right? Meaning, it's hoof will
reach as far as his eye sees.
How is this animal low item.
That's the only details that we
have about him We don't know
what color it was. We don't
know what it looks like
exactly. Some imagery that
Muslims have drawn of Al Burak
is basically a horse with
wings. This obviously has
nothing to do with Barak. The
prophet didn't mention that it
had wings. As a matter of fact,
that is under the assumption
that he rode Alburaq in his
ascension and that's not
correct. He rode the Boraq from
to Medina. He tied there and
then he ascended. Not that he
ascended into the heavens on
Albarak. That's a
misunderstanding that many
people have. So, all of these
kinds of imagery that we see in
certain later parts of the
Muslim empire where artists
were given a lot more liberty
to draw such things. These
things should never be drawn
obviously but some of them have
tried to capture
or symbolize with certain
imagery being you know a horse
with wings or what have you.
All of this is incorrect. And
this imagery is is not
something that the Muslims do.
This is something that usually
comes from. paganism and
idolaters usually are the ones
that draw and depict such
things in drawing it. So I say
this because
Many Muslims, especially in the
English speaking Muslims have
seen some of these images,
right? They've seen some of
these images. has anybody
here ever seen that? Al
Barack with the wings and
that's even I've seen some
books of Sierra that have the
pictures on the cover. Right?
So you have the dove on the
cover and you have the spider
on the cover and you have a
barak on the cover. This
obviously has nothing to do
with what really happened and
you know honestly putting
imagery that on a book of
knowledge, especially a book as
illustrious as one that claims
to capture the biography of the
prophet cheapens, cheapens the
entire experience. This is not
a fairy tale, right? This is
not you know, Snow White and
the Seven Dwarfs. This is not
you know, Pinocchio. This is
not a fairy tale. This is a
real thing that the messenger
of Allah went through and did.
We should never ever accept
that these things be cheapened
by drawings and depictions and
so forth. This is something
that the scholarship of Islam
has unanimously rejected from
the inception.
This ascension happened after
the journey, the night journey.
So, when we say
right? So, it's two things.
It's two things that occurred.
What's mentioned in the Quran
explicitly is the Israt, the
Night Journey, right? Al Part
is mentioned in the explicit
narrations of the prophet and
it from was taken into the
heavens. I was made to ascend.
These two things are connected
because in the correct opinion,
these two things happen on the
same night and they only happen
once. They did not happen
multiple times. And the
ascension happened after the
night journey. And the night
journey was with his body and
his soul and the ascension was
with his body and soul. He he
traveled from Mecca to Al
Masjid al Aqsa on Il Barak.
Then he tied off Al Barak and
ascended into the heavens
without Alburaq. Okay? Just so
we can kind of get a full
picture here. I know that many
of us have read stuff or or
seen other things that are
contrary to that. And that's
because a lot of things were
written that shouldn't have
been. that's enough for
tonight. We'll continue next
week with
[Arabic recitation]